no no I all my life I felt that Native
Americans have been the most neglected
of all minorities in this country and
all my life I fought for them as a
congressman this is what they want they
were stolen their land and in exchange
the federal government was supposed to
give them health care and education and
what is called self-determination treat
them as fully fully elected governments
and we don't do that in fact we don't
keep our commitment for health care we
don't keep our commitment for education
as a result the highest poverty rate
suicide rates diabeetus alcoholism or an
Indian reservations I would change that
as president eleven percent of my state
is Native American and I have elevated
Native Americans to a cabinet status and
we do everything we can to make for the
federal shortfalls but what I would do
as president I would elevate Native
American affairs to a cabinet level
these are human beings these are the
first Americans and we didn't keep our
promise to the first Americans and this
just means treating them equally doesn't
mean giving them special privileges
today the highest rates of poverty of
the highest rates of suicide you go
anywhere in this country are in our
reservations around particularly in the
West
you